hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so very quickly for
those who are watching my video for the
first time let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trader for the past six
years in
hong kong and i've just decided to make
some youtube videos because guys i want
to pass
the knowledge i want to show you all the
different tools and techniques
that i like to use at work to make money
on the markets and in my videos i want
to show you how to do it yourself
so today i want to make a big update
guys on amc
and have a look on the longer term let's
get into it
[Music]
so usually i start on the first time
frame in this video i want to start on
the daily time frame
and we are taking a step back guys and i
want to
show you what to me is actually playing
out
so i'm talking about the 35 level for a
long time we're not there yet but we are
going there
and once we're gonna reach this let's
see
if what might happen so once again we're
not there yet let me quickly
sum up the situation of what happened
this year so we had this strong move up
guys uh from you know the
two area to 25
roughly developing in five waves all
right as usual moves up developing five
waves guys
then we had this correction abc three
waves
and then you know there was kind of a
question
are we gonna correct more or are we
gonna start a new
bull cycle and when i saw that here we
had those
five waves very clean one two three
four five and i'm not gonna zoom in but
if i do
each impulse here the third the fifth
and even the first
can be broken down in five waves too
which is actually telling us that we are
bullish all right so this is a very good
information you can use
from idiot wave theory is that if you
see a move
developing in five waves it's a motive
wave it means that the market
is gonna keep developing probably in
this direction
so from there i know that we are bullish
and
i know that i'm expecting here this
correction that happened
and here i was trying you know to time
the rebound
which was not easy we had you know some
kind of tricks
done by the market and it was
not that clean for me but anyways
we still had our signals that were
quite clear when they happened for
example one of the signals i used guys
to know that we are gonna start
having uh stronger moves is this one the
same i'm using on gamestop guys
all right on gamestop we just broke it i
didn't do the video yet i'm gonna do it
very soon but we just broke
this level right and here when we break
this
you know in inside the first wave then
we have the second wave correct
put the corrective second wave and then
we know that we having the third wave
that is going to be the most
impulsive one the strongest one with
strong associated volumes
so here we have our abc then we have we
are having again after
a one two three four five abc we're
gonna start again one two three four
five
which is actually the third wave of this
move that is happening here so here i'm
going to give you my different scenarios
right now we are in the third wave of
this third wave
so the blue one here and this is why
when i did my video
last weekend guys i told you that you
know 12
would probably hold that this deep
because we had
some you know consideration here was
nothing and that we're expecting
some very strong moves to come this week
which we
had so now i might have one or two days
delay on this video but it doesn't
matter
what i'm not sure if we broke 17 or not
i'm not sure if we got
a bit rejected uh to the 15 level or not
it's not important guys you know what is
important is that
this wave is still developing and we are
only in the third wave
of this purple third wave so the
question is
where is it heading and for now it's too
early to answer this question
we first need to know where the third
wave is going to go
and then uh how the fifth wave is is
developing but for sure
we can expect something like this so
let's say we correct to 15 which is you
know kind of my preferred scenario
then we're gonna have a one two three
four five
maybe like this so this is one of my
scenarios
and either we go to 35 then it means
that we're gonna correct maybe to 25 or
even 17
and then do a few slaves that is going
to blow up everything
because 35 guys i remind you is our
all-time high
if i check on the weekly time frame
you see guys 35 is not a random level is
the all-time high
and this is why i think we are first
getting there and probably
gonna break it if we arrive there with
enough strength so
let me come back here so let's see let's
see what we're having guys
the third wave might even break the 35
level itself you know this is possible
as well
but most likely it will be the maximum
of this
third wave and then let's see how deep
we correct but we know that we're gonna
have
one move up that's why we need some time
i have told you guys that the 35 level
would be reached this summer
i told you guys this you know a long
time ago some of you
you know we're not sure i was just
saying this
to make more views up because i really
believed and
i mean it's my analysis that is telling
me what to tell you guys and
for now what i can tell you for sure is
that
this third wave is gonna last i think
until the end of june and this is when
we're gonna have more information if yes
or no we're gonna break 35
uh quickly or not so i want to now
show you some very cool option
strategies
that you can make guys to actually
benefit
from this whole move up that is
happening right now
so i wanted to show you guys this
strategy so basically
very quickly let me remind you what is a
call option is an option that
is gonna pay you the performance above a
given level that we call the strike so
the formula is the maximum between zero
and spot which is your spot level minus
k which is
the strike and by using call options
you can actually make some nice option
strategies so here the one i want to
show you guys is what we call
a butterfly so a butterfly is
a payoff that has this kind of shape
where you have some wings that's why we
call it a butterfly
and a body and to build this
strategy so for example you can do it
like this so you can buy the 2011
[Music]
if i take the june maturity and i take a
butterfly that is 20 30
40 so let's we're going to check the
prices very soon
so basically you buy for example 50 call
option of the 20 strike call
then you sell 100 options of the 30
strike call which is
here so all right so if you just buy
the call option you're like this then
you sell here 100
so you're gonna take the opposite
direction on the downside and then you
want to cap your loss you don't want to
lose above
40. so you buy here 50 as well
and then you're like this you're having
a butterfly so now let's take the prices
of
those options so that we know the price
of this strategy so i'm gonna show you
guys
exactly how you can do it yourself you
just go
on yahoo finance
all right
you type amc you go on the option chain
which is here guys
you take the june maturity which is very
liquid where you're gonna have
tight blast spreads and you check the
prices
so we are now on the june maturity so
let's let's check the prices so the 40
strike is at 66. so let's say we buy at
67 let's say we cross the bid ask spread
so 67 30 we're gonna sell it at 91
and the 20 is at 190 so
the 20 is at 190 this one we're going to
sell it
91 we said and we buy this one at 67
and here i just compute my premium and
bam
all right so this would cost you guys so
maybe it's a bit
too much let's take 3000 us dollars but
you can make
up to 40 000 so let's say you do
you know 10 times less up
now it costs only 400 us dollars so it's
the same strategies and you can make
up to five thousand five hundred now the
strategy i would make myself i would go
to the 25
you know i would here sell 7.5
okay so it's roughly the same basically
the number of uh options you're having
here must be zero otherwise you're gonna
have a problem and the 25
is probably cheaper so the 25 costs
133 so once again i consider i cross
the bid ask spread so it's going to be
actually cheaper than this guys
because if you just put your order in
between the bid and the ask
you're gonna see that you have a lot of
iceberg orders
which means some hidden orders between
those levels
that you can be executed on so
1.27 all right so now 420 us dollar so
this is you know
much more reasonable you can make up to
2500 us
dollars all right so i just wanted to
show you guys you know the kind of
strategies you can make
how you can check the premium the total
premium you're gonna pay
and the kind of payoff that you might
have
and i think that this is very
interesting to do
on uh stock like amc because you are
selling actually
the upside call options you you see here
you're not only buying
you're buying the 25 but you're selling
the 30 because the volatility is very
high on those
strikes that the premium of your total
strategy
is not that big so guys that's it for me
i hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to floor i'll see you
guys